Schönen guten Tag, mein Name ist Akpınar. Ich bin heute der Diensthabender Arzt für Sie.
Ich werde mich um Ihre Beschwerden kümmern, aber bevor wir anfangen, brauche ich Ihren persönlichen Daten.
Sind Sie nicht verstanden oder haben Sie andere Fragen? Bitte geben Sie Bescheid.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Sarah Blauspita.
Sarah Blauspita. Könnten Sie bitte Ihren Vor- und Nachnamen deutlich und langsam beschreiben?
S.A.R.A.H. Sarah B.L.A.U.S.V.I.T.E.R.
Um sicher zu sein, möchte ich wiederholen.
S.A.R.A.S. Samuel, A.W.Anton, R.W.Richard, A.W.Heimrich und das Name B.W.Bertzer, L.W.Ludwig, A.W.Anton, U.W.Ullrich, Sten Stettelin und V.W.Hallen, I.W.Ida, T.W.Theodor, R.W.Richard. Ist das richtig?
Richtig, ja.
Ich spreche Ihren Vor- und Nachnamen deutlich aus. Sarah Blauspita. Ist das richtig?
Ja, richtig.
Frau Blauspita, wie alt sind Sie denn?
55.
55, ok. Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
23.07.1941
Wie groß sind Sie?
Oh, ja. Ich bin 1,63 Meter.
Wie viel wiegen Sie zurzeit, Frau Blauspita?
Gestern habe ich mich, mein Gewicht gewogen, das war 85,3 Kilo.
85,3 Kilo. Danke für die Informationen.
Was führt Sie heute zu uns? Können Sie bitte Ihre Beschwerden erläutern?
Ja, ich verspüre mich total erschöpft.
Ich habe auch Konzentrationsstörungen.
Außerdem muss ich, wenn ich Auto fahre, immer für einige Stunden die Augen schließen.
Und ich soll auch um meine Enkelkinder sich kümmern.
Aber es geht nicht mehr so. Ich kann nicht arbeiten. Es geht nicht mehr.
Ok. Es tut mir leid, zu hören, dass Sie schon gesagt haben, dass Sie viele Probleme haben, z.B. Müdigkeit, Konzentrationsstörungen.
Frau Blauspita, haben Sie andere Probleme?
Ja, Kopfschmerzen habe ich.
Das heißt, morgendliche Kopfschmerzen. Seit 2-3 Stunden geht es weg.
Vielleicht kann ich nicht gut schlafen.
In der Nacht muss ich dreimal die Toilette gehen.
Mein Mann hat mir gesagt, dass ich in der Nacht auch kochen und im Hals wügen.
Wissen Sie, was das ist?
Würgen ist ein komischer Geräusch während des Schlafens. Aber machen Sie keine Sorge, ich werde eine Lösung finden.
Mein Mann hat gesagt, dass ich in der Nacht Atemunterbrechen habe.
Seit einer Woche schläft er nicht mit mir. Er schläft, weil ich laute Schnarchen habe.
Frau Blauspita, seit wann haben Sie Schlafstörungen? Fangen wir mit Ihren Schlafproblemen an?
Seit 6 Wochen. Aber meine Müdigkeit ist seit 3-4 Wochen schlimmert geworden.
Schlafen Sie auf dem Rücken oder auf der Seite?
Da bin ich mir nicht sicher. Weiß ich nicht.
Sie haben schon gesagt, dass Sie nachts Atempose haben.
Weiter atmen Sie durch den Mund oder durch die Nase?
Das bemerke ich nicht. Aber morgen trinke ich auch etwas Wasser.
Vielleicht trinke ich beim Mund. Sie haben recht.
Wie viel Wasser trinken Sie täglich?
Normalerweise. Aber in der Nacht trinke ich auch ein Glas Wasser.
Wie oft müssen Sie in der Nacht zur Toilette gehen?
Wie habe ich gesagt? 3 Mal?
Entschuldigung, ich höre nicht akustisch.
Frau Blauspita, wie viele Stunden schlafen Sie?
Vielleicht 6 oder 8 Stunden. Aber 3 oder 2 Mal aufwachen.
Frau Blauspita, Sie haben schon gesagt, dass Sie Kopfschmerzen haben.
Ich möchte ein bisschen Informationen sammeln.
Sie haben Kopfschmerzen und Schlafprobleme?
Seit 6 Monaten habe ich morgendliche Kopfschmerzen.
Haben Sie irgendwelche Medikamente dagegen angenommen?
Nein.
Wo genau haben Sie Kopfschmerzen?
Im ganzen Kopf.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie Kopfschmerzen nur morgendlich haben.
Gibt es etwas, das zu bestimmten Zeiten auftritt?
Morgen, wenn ich aufwache, geht es innerhalb von 2 Stunden weg.
Dauert es ungefähr 2 Stunden?
Ja.
Frau Blauspita, haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen?
Brennende Gefühle oder Veränderungen?
Nein. Normales Urin und eine normale Menge.
Ich habe einige Fragen zu Ihrem Allgemeinen Zustand.
Haben Sie Fieber?
Nein.
Nachschweiß und Schweißausbrüche oder vermehrte Schwitzen?
Haben Sie ein Brüchchenfühl oder Luftnot?
Nein.
Sind Sie übel oder haben Sie eine Erbrechung?
Haben Sie Probleme beim Stuhlgang?
Seit 3 Jahren habe ich Verstopfung.
Ich habe auch Verdammungsprobleme.
Wie oft müssen Sie zur Toilette gehen?
2 Mal pro Woche.
Frau Blauspita, waren Sie früher beim Arzt?
Nein.
Ich bin auch Krankenschwester.
Ich bin obese.
Ich kann nicht Sport treiben.
Ich muss meine Enkelkinder aufpassen.
Deswegen denke ich so.
Aber nein, ich habe keine Besuchung.
Frau Blauspita, das kann wichtig sein.
Ich empfehle einen Hausarzt zu besuchen.
Wie ist Ihre Partie?
Gut, normal.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit Ab- oder Zuhilfe genommen?
Seit 3 Jahren habe ich 20 Kilo abgenommen.
Sie haben gesagt, Sie sind 25 Jahre alt.
Ich vermute, Sie sind in der Menopause.
Ist das richtig?
Seit 10 Jahren bin ich in der Menopause.
Haben Sie genokologische Probleme?
Nein, Gott sei Dank.
Ich besuche meinen Arzt jährlich.
Alles klar.
Frau Blauspita, gibt es irgendwelche Erkrankungen,
von denen ich wissen sollte, zum Beispiel Bluthochdruck, Blutzucker oder erhöhte Blutetwerte?
Ich habe Bluthochdruck seit 3 Jahren und Hypercholesterinämie seit 5 Jahren.
Ich nehme meine Medikamente regelmäßig ein.
Das ist 80 mg Walzartan morgens und 10-20 mg Liproset morgens.
Okay. Außer Walzartan und Liproset nehmen Sie andere Medikamente ein?
Nein.
Frau Blauspita, gibt es irgendwelche Operationen in der Vergangenheit?
Können Sie bitte erklären?
Bei mir würde mir die Galenblase entfernt.
Galenblase?
Vor 10 Jahren war alles komplikationslos.
Ich habe eine Frage bezüglich Allergien und Verständlichkeiten.
Haben Sie oder gibt es irgendwelche Allergien?
Zum Beispiel Zähne oder Schmerzen?
Nur in der braunen Flasche habe ich Allergien.
Es ist mit Pyruritis und Erhitem verwendet.
Pyruritis und Erhitem?
Ja, Kreis und Rott-Halb.
Jetzt habe ich eine Frage zu Lebensgewohnheiten.
Frau Blauspita, rauchen Sie?
Nein, früher auch nicht.
Konsumiert ihr Alkohol?
Am Wochenende, nur am Samstag, zwei Gläser Wein.
Darf ich fragen, ob Sie jemals Kontakt mit Drogen hatten?
Nein, aber warum fragen Sie das?
Das ist eine reine Routinefrage.
Sie wissen, dass viele Drogen mit anderen Medikamenten haben.
Diese Information ist sehr wichtig für uns.
Das ist eine Routinefrage.
Jetzt habe ich eine Frage zu Gesundheitszuständen Ihrer Eltern und Geschwistern.
Bestände bei Ihnen irgendwelche Erkrankungen?
Sind Sie gesund?
Mein Vater leidet an wie ich Bluthochdruck.
Er ist jetzt 70 Jahre alt.
Meine Mutter ist mit 69 Jahren alt an Busanfall gestorben.
Er sieht auch Busanfall.
Sie leidet auch an Depression.
Sie hat Schwermütigkeit.
Was denken Sie, ist das erblich Schwermütigkeit?
Ich kann nicht 100% sagen, aber manchmal haben Ihre Eltern gemütliche Erkrankungen.
Natürlich ist das eine Erhütung für Sie.
Aber wir werden heute Ihre Situation abklären.
Ich habe Angst, vielleicht kann ich auch einen Autounfall bekommen.
Was kann ich tun?
Können Sie mir helfen?
Das ist verständlich.
Sie haben schon gesagt, dass Sie ein bisschen angenäht haben.
Aber ich empfehle Ihnen, bis wir eine Diagnose feststellen.
Oder einige passende Behandlungen beginnen.
Bitte fahren Sie nicht Auto.
Das kann nicht nur gefährlich sein, sondern auch andere Teilnehmer gefährlich sein.
Sie haben einen Ehemann.
Haben Sie Kinder und sind Sie gesund?
Ja, ich habe zwei Tochter und zwei Enkelkinder.
Gott sei Dank. Die beiden sind gesund.
Ich habe gehört, dass Sie Krankenschwestern sind.
Arbeiten Sie noch?
Leider vor zwei Wochen habe ich von meinem Hausarzt krankgeschrieben.
Weil ich zu müde war.
Vielen Dank, Frau Bulaus-Zwitsa.
Wir sind fertig.
Ich bedanke mich für Ihre Offenheit.
Nachdem Sie die Situation auf Ihren Krankenschwächs haben, habe ich einen Verdacht auf schlafenbezogene Atemstörungen.
Das ist ein Verdacht.
Ich werde Sie körperlich untersuchen.
Danach etwas Blut abnehmen.
Gegebenenfalls weitere Untersuchungen durchführen.
Nach dem Ergebnis oder sobald alle Befünde vorliegen, komme ich gleich und wir werden Ihre Situation Schritt für Schritt besprechen.
Haben Sie etwas zu fragen oder haben Sie etwas hinzufügen, Frau Bulaus-Zwitsa?
Nein, alles klar. Vielen Dank für Ihre Aufmerksamkeit.
Danke schön. Bitte nehmen Sie Platz.
Okay, danke.
Gut gemacht.
Ich bin sehr glücklich.
Hücük Hücük, möchtest du einen Anruf machen?
Ja, bitte.
Kling, Kling.
Akpunar Amapara, bitte.
Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Können Sie diese Werte mit oder als Teilen?
Frau Mühler hat einen Hemoglobinwert von 5,6 Gramm Dessiliter.
Können Sie das mit Teilen?
Ja.
Frau Mühler.
Danke schön. Tschüss.
Bis bald.
Okay.
Guten Tag, Herr Akpunar.
Schönen Tag.
Was haben Sie heute für uns?
Ich habe einen neuen Patienten betreut.
Aber bevor wir anfangen,
muss ich eine kurze Anmerkung machen.
Darf ich?
Ja, natürlich.
Gleich habe ich einen Anruf aus dem Labor bekommen.
Unbedingt soll ich Ihnen berichten,
wenn Frau Mühler einen Hemoglobinwert von 5,6 Gramm Dessiliter hat.
Dieser Wert ist deutlich erniedrigt und entspricht einer Anämie.
Okay.
Wissen Sie, welche Art von Anämie es gibt?
Entschuldigung, ich habe nie diesen Patienten gesehen.
Aber zuerst würde ich gerne untersuchen.
Ich habe nicht gefragt, nach welchen Patienten.
Ich habe einfach gefragt, wissen Sie, welche Art von Anämie es gibt?
Nur Hemoglobinwert ist nicht ausreichend für mich.
Ich brauche weitere Tests zu machen, zum Beispiel MCW, Ferritin, Transferrin, Vitamin...
Aber Herr Akpunar,
ich frage diese Patienten.
Ich frage einfach, welche Art von Anämie es gibt.
Entschuldigung, ich verstehe für diese Patienten.
Es gibt drei verschiedene Anämie.
Und Hypochrom, Normochrom und Macrochrom.
Macros der Anämie.
Und wir werden alle Anämie-Typen bezüglich ihrer weiteren Labortests,
zum Beispiel MCW, Ferritin, Transferrin, Vitamin 12 und...
Obfuscitate MCH.
Mittlerweile mit einer körperlichen Volumen.
Und ist nur im Bereich von 85 bis ungefähr 100 Femtoliter.
Wenn Patienten eine niedrige MCW,
dann bedeutet das eine Mikros der Anämie.
Und über 100 Femtoliter ist eine Macros der Anämie.
Aber wenn die Ergebnisse im Normbereich sind,
bedeutet das eine Normochrom-Anämie.
Welche Symptome erwarten Sie bei Anämie?
Die häufigsten Symptome sind Müdigkeit,
Konzentrationsstörungen, Vergessenheit,
Schwitzen, Haarausfall,
Tachikardiasis, Herzrasen, Luftnot,
Bewegungbelastung oder Leistungsunfähigkeit.
Anämie verursacht viele Symptome.
Und ja.
Okay. Und was haben Sie noch für uns heute?
Nun würde ich gerne die ersten Patienten präsentieren.
Danke schön für Ihre Möglichkeiten.
Und es geht um Sarah Blauswitzer.
Ich glaube, Sie sagen nicht vielen Dank für Ihre Möglichkeiten in der Prüfung.
Sie müssen schon.
Das ist nicht unnötig. Danke schön für Ihre Bemerkungen.
Sie finden es ein bisschen komisch,
deswegen sprechen Sie darüber.
Manchmal sprechen Sie darüber und verursachen viele Schwierigkeiten für mich.
Sarah Blauswitzer ist 55-jährige Patientin.
Sie wurde am 24.07.1971 1,63 Meter groß.
Sie wiegt ca. 89,3 Kilo.
Unsere Patientin Sarah Blauswitzer kam heute zu uns wegen bestehender Müdigkeit und Konzentrationsstörungen.
Sie klagte begleitend über diese Beschwerden.
Seit wann hat sie diese Beschwerden?
Seit ungefähr sechs Wochen.
Sie hat seit sechs Wochen diese Beschwerden gehabt.
Begleitend klagte sie über morgendliche Kopfschmerzen,
tägliche Schlepplichkeit,
die Somnie, die ist eine sehr wichtige Beschwerde für Sie.
Sie braucht keinen Stress.
Sie hat eine sehr wichtige Beschwerde für Sie.
Ihr Ehemann hat gemerkt, dass sie laufende Schnarchen und Atempausen bei Schlaf hat.
Ich надszyst' viel Musik zu sein.
Sie hat diese Frage gut eingestellt?
Noch nicht gefragt, aber in der Körpervers yeter
kann ich das kontrollieren.
Okay. Aber bei der Körperleuntersuchung,
ihren Blutdruck zu messen, ist nicht genug.
Ja.
Weil sie morgens Kopfschmerzen hat.
Morgen der Kopfschmerzen kann meistens durch unkontrolliert arteriöle Hypertäne
oder durch Schlafapne-Syndrom auftreten.
Deswegen ist diese Frage sehr wichtig bei diesem Fall.
Ja. Und die Hyperlipidemie seit drei Jahren,
Medikamentos nimmt sie 80 mg einmal täglich,
Lipid-Reset 10-20 mg einmal täglich ein.
Warum ist Lipid-Reset 10-20 mg?
Diese Perfektion hat zwei Arsenalmitten,
das ist eine Kombinationtherapie für Lipid-Senkung.
Okay.
In der operativen Anamnese würde bei ihnen
Cholesthystoktomie durchgeführt und
bestrückliche Allergien und Unverträglichkeiten
ist bei ihnen Bramflasterallergien bekannt.
Sie reagiert darauf als Pyrrhythmias und Erythemat.
Bei der Noxanamnese ist sie nicht rauchend,
sie ist nicht rauchend, konsumiert,
konsumiert gelbend nicht Alkohol,
Drogenkonsum wird dafür nicht.
Die Familienanamnese ergab
arteriöliche Persönlichkeiten beim Vater
und Depressionen bei der Mutter.
Aber ihre Mutter ist an einem Busanfall gestorben.
Frau Blauswitzer ist Krankenschwester,
aber seit zwei Wochen nicht noch arbeiten hat.
Sie hat zwei Tochter und zwei Enkelkinder.
Nach der Anamnese habe ich einen Verdacht auf
Obstruktives Schlafapno-Syndrom.
Und Differentialdiagnostik kommen in einiges.
Wofür spricht Obstruktives Schlafapno-Syndrom?
Schlafstörungen, Bronchopathy,
Übergewicht, tägliche Müdigkeit,
Schwitzen und Adipositas.
Wie schon gesagt, Entschuldigung.
Und nicht Türe.
Differentialdiagnostik kommt an太太 und Hypertriose.
in Betracht.
Wofür spricht Hypertriose?
Hypertriose, Konzentration became Schlafstörungen,
Müdigkeit, Schlafstörungen werden in die beiden,
Aber das ist ein Verdacht und ich vermute das.
Aber damit Sie eine Hypothrose vermutet haben Sie ein paar Zeichen.
Hypothrose?
Ja, Sie haben recht.
Sie hat seit 3 Jahren eine Verstopfung und Gewichtszunahme.
20 kg von 20 kg in 3 Jahren.
Sie sind auf Beschwerden für Hypothrose?
Ja.
Ich bin in der 8.
Welche Diagnostik Methoden möchten Sie durchführen?
Um meine Verdacht Diagnose zu bestätigen und die Differenziöldiagnose auszusiedeln, würde ich zuerst körperliche Untersuchungen und etwas Blut abnehmen.
Im Labor würde ich Blutbild, Blutsyke, Schulterosen, Hormone, Liberwerte, Nierenwerte, Vitamin B12, Kohlisäure, Entzündungskalämete und ...
Was ist das?
Das ist ein Schlaflabor.
Ich empfehle den Patienten eine Schlaflabor.
Das ist eine Schlaflabor.
Schliessen oder Absuklarin?
Absuklarin.
Was bedeutet das? Wie läuft die Polysomnographie? Wie wird die Polysomnographie durchgeführt?
Polysomnographie ist eine Untersuchung, bei der wir verschiedene Parameter beim Schlaf beurteilen.
Beispiel E.E.G., Elektroentzaphalographie, Elektrookulographie, Elektrocardiographie und Sauerstoffsättigung, Bewegungparameter, zum Beispiel Beinbewegung und Atempause beurteilen und Atemfrequenz, Herzfrequenz.
Ja.
Okay.
Und Sie können auch sagen, dass die Patienten in einer Nacht in den Einrichtungen übernachten sollten, damit die Polysomnographie durchgeführt werden kann.
Wie können Sie die Patienten behandeln?
Je nach Laborergebnis würde ich zuerst die Ambulantherapie behandeln.
Aber Lebensstilveränderungen sind auch sehr wichtig für unsere Patienten.
Zum Beispiel Gewicht reduzieren, Diets, Anpassende Diets machen, regelmäßig Sport treiben und Alkohol reduzieren.
Und dann würde ich gerne alle Passendetherapien empfehlen.
Okay. Was ist die Haupttherapie für diese Patienten?
Wenn Schlaflabortest oder Polysomnographie ein schweres Schlafabnehmungszentrum besteignet ist, empfehle ich natürlich ein Step-Up-Gerät für unsere Patienten.
Ein Atem-Helfgerät beim Schlaf.
Das fördert Atemzustand in der Nacht und das vermindert erniedrige Sauerstoffstätigung.
Das kann helfen, wenn Sie eine Beschwerden haben.
Okay. Vielen Dank, Herr Akdop.
Danke schön.
Haben Sie Fragen an mich?
Nicht Fragen. Danke schön für Ihre Unterstützung.
Das ist ein schwieriger Fall für mich.
Ossas ist nicht ein einfacher Fall.
Ich habe ein paar Lösungen.
Ich glaube, dass es bei Anamnesen keine Probleme gibt.
Aber wenn Sie Anamnesen die Patientenwissen zurückgeben, verinnern Sie sich manchmal an die Fälle.
Wenn Sie eine Anamnesen-Probleme haben, dann verinnern Sie sich an die Anamnesen.
Wenn Sie eine Anamnesen-Probleme haben, verinnern Sie sich an die Anamnesen.
Wenn die Sitzung lang ist, verinnern Sie sich an die Anamnesen.
Wenn Sie an der Anamnesen-Probleme sind, verinnern Sie sich an die Anamnesen.
Das ist nicht der Fall.
Ich hätte es nicht verstanden, die Anamnesen zu vermitteln.
Ich habe es gesagt, aber ich habe die meisten von den Patienten nicht verstanden.
Ich habe sie nicht verstanden.
Ich habe sie verstanden.
Ich wollte, dass sie an der Anamnesen-Probleme vermitteln.
Sie hat sie nicht verstanden.
Sie hat sie in ein paar Sekunden gesagt.
Ich wollte mit der ersten Schlafen beginnen, aber sie hat das Kopfschulversum gesagt.
Sie hat sie verstanden.
Sie hat mich verstanden.
Aber Sie müssen sich nicht um diese Anamnesen verhalten.
Sie müssen sich die Anamnesen-Probleme verhalten.
Es kann z.Bные páw Pode sein, companies reinen anderen undzipeln.
Es kann z.B. mainstreams reinen anderen undzipeln.
S Jana,anes
S woman es acho.
Ich habe es verstanden.
Du kannst hier einen Übergang machen.
Dann sagt der Patient hier vieles selbst.
Um zu hören und zu beweisen, was er hört,
kannst du nur das, was du hörst, zurückgeben.
Und du kannst Reaktionen zeigen.
Denn die Symptome, die er zeigt,
beeinflussen deine Leben.
Zum Beispiel, wenn du mit deinem Mann nicht zu Hause bist,
kannst du nur so sagen,
dass du nicht mit ihm zu Hause bist.
Das kann auch für deine Beziehung schwierig sein.
Oder, ich kann meine Tochter nicht mit ihm zu Hause.
Das kann nur so sein.
Du kannst das, was du verstehst, zurückgeben.
Und dann deine Reaktionen zeigen.
Und um Fragen zu stellen,
kannst du nur so sagen, dass du nicht mit ihm zu Hause bist.
Das ist meine Anerkennung.
Und man spricht von Ankle Kindle.
Wie kann ein Mensch mit Ankle Kindle sein?
Sollte er als Kind sein?
Also, anstatt anzusehen,
kann man sich mit einem Fisch mit Ankle Kindle fragen.
Das kann auch schön sein.
So ist es.
Ich glaube, wie ich es gesagt habe,
ist Anamnese keine Probleme.
Das kann auch mit meinen Sachen ausgehen.
Ich werde es nicht machen, wenn es in dieser Art geht.
Aber wenn es nicht geht, werde ich Dinge fragen.
Ich werde die Schlafabne-Sendung fragen.
Ich werde die anderen Anleitungen fragen,
die er nicht gesagt hat.
Das ist es.
So ist es.
Wenn Anamnese nicht vorhanden ist,
wenn er nicht zu Beginn sagt,
dann ist es so.
So ist es.
Es ist wichtig,
vorhandene Anleitungen zu machen.
Wenn man sich an der Zeit müde ist,
kann man es manchmal schwer machen.
Oder wenn man nicht die Anamnese
vorhanden ist,
kann es vielleicht nicht so sein.
Wenn es um den Patienten geht,
dann kommt es mit Müdigkeit und Konzentration.
Der Patient kann die Anleitungen nicht so erzählen.
Aber er hat es schon gesagt.
Dann könnt ihr es selbst machen.
Ihr müsst die Anleitungen nicht so erzählen.
Sagt nur die Anleitungen.
Aber macht es selbst.
Das ist es.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Sie sind Wechseljahre.
Aber der Patient ist 60 Jahre alt.
Diese Frage ist richtig.
Und andere sind Menopause.
Das ist die Information.
Ich habe keine Details.
Bei diesen Patienten ist das nicht wichtig.
Vielleicht kann es wichtig sein.
Die häufigkeit ist ...
Ich denke, Menopause ist ein Diskvakt für diese Patienten.
Deswegen sollten wir diese Fragen stellen.
Aber ich weiß nicht,
ob diese andere Menschen sind.
Sie sind Wechseljahre.
Sie sind in Menopause.
Das ist eine sehr besondere Frage. Ich halte das in Ordnung, aber wir müssen die Qualität ein bisschen erhöhen.
Ich denke, dass wir uns hier ein bisschen umsetzen müssen.
Das ist auch ein Thema meiner Arbeit.
Deshalb wollte ich Sie fragen.
Herr Professor, das ist in den Erfahrungen, in der Simulation-Gruppe von Danis, sehr oft gefragt.
Ich habe mich selbst gefragt.
Sie haben uns selbst gefragt.
Wenn ein Patient eine abdominalische Erkrankung hat, oder wenn der Patient, der Menopausexperte,
ob das wichtig ist, wenn es ein Risiko ist, ist das ein Tod.
Und die Schreie können manchmal auch mit Menopausexperten verbunden sein.
Das ist auch wichtig.
Aber wenn es etwas ohne Beinahe zu tun hat, wenn es keine Bauchschmerzen gibt,
dann kann man es nicht fragen, wenn es Zeit hat.
Das ist ein Thema, Herr Professor.
Ich habe es verstanden.
Meine Frage ist,
wenn man eine Wechseljahre hat,
das ist ein bisschen theoretisch,
aber wenn man eine Wechseljahre hat, kann man eine Wechseljahre als Klima-Tür bezeichnen.
Deshalb kann man eine Wechseljahre in dieser Zeit sehen, aber sie hat eine lange Zeit,
sie hat nur ein paar Schikerte, aber die Menopausexperte können das nicht sehen.
Ich bin ein Patient,
und ich habe keine Menopausexperte.
Du sagst, dass eine Wechseljahre nicht eine Menopausexperte ist.
Deswegen...
Ich weiß das.
Ich weiß, dass eine Menopausexperte ist.
Eine Wechseljahre und eine Menopausexperte sind nicht die gleichen Dinge.
Was?
Sie sind nicht die gleichen Dinge.
Ist eine Wechseljahre eine Menopausexperte oder eine Klima-Tür?
Eine Menopausexperte ist ein Problem.
Eine Wechseljahre ist eine Klima-Tür, Herr Professor.
Sie sind nicht die gleichen Dinge.
Ich weiß nicht.
Ein Patient ist 60 Jahre alt.
Eine Wechseljahre ist eine Wechseljahre,
aber eine Menopausexperte ist eine Zindein.
Das ist das, was ich hier wissen möchte.
Herr Professor, die letzte Antwort ist,
dass eine Wechseljahre nicht eine Menopausexperte ist.
Okay, okay.
Eine Wechseljahre ist eine Menopausexperte, Herr Professor.
Okay, danke.
Es gibt andere Fragen, die wir hier haben.
Eine Wechseljahre ist eine Menopausexperte.
Die Deutschen wissen die Menopausexperte.
Aber eine Wechseljahre ist eine Menopausexperte.
Sie wissen das?
Ja, die Deutschen wissen das.
Sie wissen, dass es eine Probleme ist,
wenn man eine Wechseljahre in Deutschland hat.
Die Deutschen wissen das.
Wir wissen das, wie es in der Medizin ist,
aber sie wissen das auch.
Ich wollte Sie wissen, dass es eine Probleme ist,
wenn ich eine Wechseljahre in Deutschland habe.
Sie wissen das.
Das ist nicht die Ursache.
Okay.
Ich habe Ihre Frage nicht richtig verstanden,
aber ich habe diese Frage selbst gefragt.
Es gibt vier Akutt-Coronavirus-Koronare, eine Frau und drei Männer.
Die letzten vier Arten waren von Erfarunk.
Es gab vier Arten.
Erfarunk war eine Frau, oder?
Ja, eine Frau.
Sie war eine Tatsachefrau.
Es wird eine besondere Frage.
Sind es noch Freunde, die von den vier Arten oder drei Arten einzigartig wissen?
Es gibt eine andere Frage.
Ich bin in der Telegram-Gruppe.
Ich gehe nicht dort.
Eine der Mentoren hat die letzten vier Arten einzigartig.
Ich würde Sie, wenn Sie wollen, in der Gruppe schicken.
Danke.
Ich wollte Sie fragen,
Sie etikettieren uns, wenn Sie mich nennen oder wir, außer euch,
wenn Sie mich nennen.
Ich nenne Sie.
Wir müssen nichts tun.
Ich habe in Deutschland in der Nähe von Meme-Follow-Up etwas gemacht.
Genekologie.
Ist es eine Art Struktur, die Sie kennen?
Manche sind ein Jahr und andere zwei Jahre alt.
Sie sind die Menschen, die sie sprechen.
Ist es eine Art Struktur?
Ich weiß nicht, was die normale Kontrolle ist.
Aber ich bin in der Nähe von Meme-Follow-Up.
Ein Mal im Jahr ist genug.
Ein Mal ist besser.
Aber ich bin nicht in der Nähe von Meme-Follow-Up.
Ich bin in der Nähe von Meme-Follow-Up.
Ein Mal im Jahr ist genug.